apple is finally implementing a brand
new battery cell technology on all of
the iPhone 15 models that are launching
in less than two months which is
extremely exciting because I did some
research and I found five big benefits
that you will experience later this year
if you decide to upgrade now the leak
comes from RG Cloud s on Twitter
claiming that apple is using a new
stacked Battery tech on the entire
iPhone 15 lineup now while we don't know
how reliable of a source this guy is his
leak actually matches up perfectly to a
bunch of other reputable leaks which
I'll show you in this video so let's get
into the first benefit which is huge
battery life gains with this new stacked
battery cell technology Apple will be
able to fit more battery within the same
package in this diagram you can see how
the previous Battery tech led to these
areas on the edges where there is empty
space that isn't being fully utilized
for are the battery's juice but with the
new stack cell tech it's able to be
folded over more closely to the edges
which can greatly increase usable
battery size ending up with more
milliamp hours and the same battery
package and this actually matches up
perfectly to a recent leak about battery
sizes getting much bigger across the
iPhone 15 lineup from around 12 percent
all the way up to 18 larger than the
iPhone 14 models now at first it didn't
really make sense how because the
dimensions of the 15 lineup were leaked
and they weren't much thicker in size
compared to the 14 but now this new
battery Tech leak makes perfect sense
and explains how the battery could get
that much larger in terms of milliamp
hours without increasing the size of the
phone by that much so in the end we'll
all be benefiting from huge battery life
gains with the new iPhone 15 lineup
without the phones being much bigger at
all and now let's get into benefit
number two which is faster charging
speed for years Apple has had a problem
with their batteries heating up too much
while charging especially wireless
charging that's probably a reason why
Apple has been limiting their Max save
charging speed to just 15 watts on their
official Max save Chargers and even with
the speed being that slow it actually
does heat up quite a bit especially
while using your phone like when
watching videos for example we just
tested a Max save charger that has a
cooling fan built into it from ESR and
it actually improved the charging speed
just because of that fan being on and
apparently Apple Insider says that the
new layered battery construction works
as a multi-pole battery rather than a
single pole allowing there to be less
resistance in the battery itself leading
to less heat and on top of that we
recently had another leak pointing to
Apple Inc increasing the max save
charging speed to 20 watts on the iPhone
15 lineup and now it makes perfect sense
why because the new stacked batteries
don't heat up as much and even better
the guy who leaked the Stacked Battery
tech also agreed saying that 20 watts of
Max safe charging is coming to the
iPhone 15 lineup with a new protocol and
powered chip but he wasn't sure if it
was going to be the iPhone 15 or 16
lineup hopefully this year and then in
another League there is a claim that
Apple would be allowing regular G2
standard charging to wirelessly charge
at up to 15 watts compared to the
current limit of 7.5 which is honestly
really annoying because it makes you not
want to use third-party Chargers so that
new leak is another bit of proof that
apple is solving their battery heat
issue allowing for faster charging and
then another thing the new leaker also
said is that we would be getting an
upgrade to 40 watt wired charging which
makes perfect sense because of the new
batteries that don't get as hot as well
as the switch to USBC which can support
more power than lightning and then this
actually brings us into benefit number
three which is battery health but first
I've got to give a shout out to our
partner case coup who makes awesome
cases like their Cloud cush case which
has air cushion technology built into
the frame so it's very drop resistant
while also being incredibly comfortable
to hold thanks to its silky smooth
rounded finish and right now they're
doing an iPad giveaway running up until
August 8th giving away an iPad to one of
the first 100 people that enter and a
second iPad if 200 people enter so use
the links down below to check out their
cases and enter the iPad giveaway today
now I'm sure you know that out of all
the smartphone companies out there Apple
cares the most about battery health even
turning on a default setting called
optimized charging which is only there
to help with battery degradation by
charging more slowly so that your
battery stays cool well apparently the
new stacked Battery tech is able to
disperse the heat evenly across the
battery cell compared to having hot
spots where the heat was more focused on
certain areas with previous battery
cells leading to less overall heat which
would previously trigger the iPhone to
slow down the charging wattage but now
with the heat being more evenly
dispersed it should allow Apple to
charge faster while still hitting their
goals for battery health or potentially
leading to even better battery longevity
in general currently apple has a problem
with some of their users still refusing
to use wireless charging because they
believe it degrades their battery too
fast well this new solution will
probably help change the narrative and
get more people switching over to
maxsafe wireless charging and if you
think about it Apple's probably gonna
ditch the physical charging port and
switch to 100 wireless charging only in
the near future and this new battery
Tech is likely required to make that
feasible now moving on to benefit number
four we have the addition of a brand new
awesome feature that hasn't really been
used much reverse wireless charging what
I mean by that is attaching a product to
the back of the iPhone and having your
iPhone charge that device using its own
battery and wireless charging coil well
believe it or not but every iPhone since
the iPhone 12 included the necessary
hardware for reverse wireless charging
to work but Apple has just kept it
inactive at least until the max save
battery pack came out which actually
allows you to plug in a cable to charge
your iPhone with your iPhone
automatically sending power to the
battery pack but of course it's been
extremely limited and very very slow and
we'd love to see the iPhone be able to
charge let's say another iPhone or
better yet your airpods from the back of
the iPhone especially now that we know
the airpods have mac safe charging
support rumors for the full activation
of the new reverse wireless charging
feature have been non-stop with people
expecting the iPhone 13 lineup to have
it and then the 14 lineup but no nothing
yet however nine to five Mac recently
heard from sources that apple is working
on unique Wireless power out firmware
including developing a special user
interface for reverse wireless charging
with on-screen animations and sound
effects and the biggest thing hold
appleback has been the issue of heat
dissipation and charging efficiency and
thankfully the new stacked Battery tech
is likely the final piece of the puzzle
before Apple finally launches reverse
wireless charging so I'm super excited
for this and finally for benefit number
five we have safety which is actually a
huge deal in light of all of the Samsung
Galaxy battery explosion drama that's
been going on for years and if you
didn't know why that happened here's a
quick explanation with a previous
traditional Battery tech it would tend
to swell and contract an inconsistent
patterns based on heat which would
deform the battery so phone
manufacturers would need to leave a
space Gap around the battery to allow it
ample space to swell without pushing up
against the internals well with how
competitive the phone space has been
companies like Samsung have been pushing
their batteries and charging speeds to
the app absolute limits to stay
competitive which caused problems with
batteries ending up exploding and on the
other hand Apple has always been very
very careful with extra space gaps and
slow charging to make sure that doesn't
happen but thankfully this new stack
Battery tech has a more stable internal
structure where the expansion force of
each layer is more similar instead of
being inconsistent and wavy so the
interface can be kept flat therefore not
requiring as much of a space Gap around
the battery which means it could be
larger while still being even more safe
and to wrap all of that together a
company named enovics just announced the
general availability of its new battery
cell which uses precise laser cut
electrodes that are stacked with
Accurate Alignment which sounds exactly
what I've been talking about in this
video so all in all this new stack
battery cell technology which is coming
to the entire iPhone 15 lineup will be a
huge advancement for Apple especially
since it'll allow for those five
benefits that I talked about so if you
enjoyed this video you can go ahead and
comment your thoughts down below and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
foreign